FANTASTIC NEGRITO:
I'm Fantastic Negrito.
There's only one Fantastic
Negrito in the world.
I googled it before
I made the name.
[LAUGHTER]
You better believe that I
did, and there was none.
And then I knew that
name was for me.
It's very hard getting up here.
Because despite being a
self-absorbed recovering
narcissist, I love
being up here.
But it's terrifying.
So I had to do my
thing in the bathroom.
I have a routine.
And I will play some
songs from the album,
"The Last Days of Oakland."
This song is kind of
like a therapy session.
[GUITAR STRUMMING]
[MUSIC - FANTASTIC NEGRITO,
"RANT RUSHMORE"]
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
It's obvious from that song
I have a lot of demons.
I have a lot of
personal problems.
But I'm willing to share them.
And that's what makes this
whole experience so beautiful.
I'm in a collective.
I think everyone should
be in a collective
because I don't have all
the power, and that's good.
In our collective, it's made
up of about-- now about five
people, I guess.
But it started off with just
two street hustling criminals
turned into creative people.
And we decided we'd
vote on everything.
So we vote on everything.
And I come out on the
losing end of that.
I actually voted against
being on the NPR Tiny Desk
competition, because
I thought just
my format didn't fit NPR because
I say bitch, nigger, pussy.
I say all kinds of things.
And I don't like political
correctness at all.
It should take a hike.
I don't want to be mean, but I
just come from a certain place.
We all come from
different places.
And I think when we can
share our experiences
and listen to each other,
then it's a real world.
Speaking of the
collective, Malcolm
Spellman, who's
here today, said,
you're a great songwriter.
You pull people in.
It's great.
But if you want to
connect with people,
I need you to stop writing
about yourself all the time.
So thank god he did that.
And so he taught me to go out,
go to the streets, the Bay
Area, and watch people, not just
attractive women, because I'll
do that, like all the time.
I'm sneaky too.
If I'm wearing shades, that
means I'm looking at you.
So it was kind of like
don't call me again
until you have a song
that's not about you.
And I came back with this.
[MUSIC - FANTASTIC NEGRITO,
"LOST IN A CROWD"]
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
That was called
"Lost in a Crowd."
I felt lost in the crowd,
singing about other people.
I wanted to sing about me.
I decided to sing
about my mother
on this last song I'm
going to do for you.
It was a remake.
It was a cover, something
I'm admittedly terrible at.
I can't do covers because
I'm such a freak on a song.
And I always want
to hear the artist
that I'm trying to cover.
I say, if they sound better.
So my idea was to take
a song that was in E
and put it in F. Ah.
And then I thought
to myself, when
they wrote that amazing,
great song that's a classic,
they didn't put a bridge in it.
So I put a bridge in it.
And the song was
so meaningful to me
because it was a
lot about washing
my 14-year-old brother's
blood off the ground.
He was a victim of gun violence.
And watching my
16-year-old cousin
lay in a coffin, and a kid that
I played with in junior high
grew up to be pretty
big time drug dealer,
which is what I
really aspired to be.
I failed.
And he was murdered
in a barber shop.
And I always thought about
my mom, the look on her face.
I thought about
my aunt, the look
on her face, all these mothers.
And they bury their children.
And I just-- I was like we're
like the greatest country,
we always say that.
But I think too frequently
maybe this happens
and people don't know about it.
So I thought that the last
act of doing the cover
was to change the lyrics, just
half of them, half of them.
Because I thought it was
just such a powerful song
and a powerful
message that I wanted
it to be relevant
to mothers who bury
their children, their babies,
which shouldn't happen.
So I thought of
my mother's face.
[MUSIC - FANTASTIC NEGRITO,
"BLACK GIRL"]
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
JAMES DRISCOLL: So first
of all, thank you for that.
FANTASTIC NEGRITO:
You're very welcome.
JAMES DRISCOLL: While
we wait for Malcolm,
I was hoping you could
tell me a little bit more
about your new album.
You just played
three songs from it.
But it's called "The
Last Days of Oakland."
FANTASTIC NEGRITO: So I
look at you or look at them.
JAMES DRISCOLL: Look at them.
FANTASTIC NEGRITO:
Like all of them,
like walk around,
like, my album--
[LAUGHTER]
MALCOLM SPELLMAN: Hello?
Hi.
FANTASTIC NEGRITO: It's called--
[LAUGHTER]
--"The Last Days of Oakland."
That's going to
take a long time.
Want me to do that every time?
JAMES DRISCOLL: Do
whatever feels natural.
Trust your instincts.
FANTASTIC NEGRITO:
You're gonna be
here-- do you have any plans
for the next eight hours?
[LAUGHTER]
He hates me right now.
Oh yeah, "The Last
Days of Oakland."
It's an album about
the end of something,
because all things end.
I'm kind of an older fella,
and I'm from the old Oakland.
I'm from the Oakland of Too
Short but at the same times
Credence Clearwater Revival.
We kind of remember it sliced
on, but we had MC Hammer.
We had En Vogue.
We had E-40.
I mean, we had some Metallica.
Very eclectic-- what's that?
AUDIENCE: Digital Underground.
FANTASTIC NEGRITO:
Digital Underground, OK.
You're a sexy guy for that one.
[LAUGHTER]
Sex packets.
So--
AUDIENCE: You had Tupac, right?
Tupac [INAUDIBLE], right?
FANTASTIC NEGRITO: I
don't know if he's going
to claim the Bay Area at all.
He doesn't really claim
the Bay Area all the way.
MALCOLM SPELLMAN: Yeah he does.
FANTASTIC NEGRITO:
Does he all the way?
So I don't know
much about Tupac.
And that was amazing.
That was incredible.
But with a lot of that
incredible creativity
and culture, there was
also a crack epidemic.
And there was some tragedy.
And sometimes things
that are amazing
come from things
that are tragic.
So he calls me the bridge.
I won't take credit for it.
So I'm kind of like the bridge.
And you know, I'm in the new
Oakland now making this music.
And there's these
new people that come
and tech and all these
amazing new people.
Let's say it out loud,
because I like to say it.
A lot of the black
people are gone.
I like to just say
things out loud.
Some people say, like,
"that neighborhood."
I'm like, no, that's
the black neighborhood.
They're gone now.
Not all of them.
I'm still here.
And--
[LAUGHTER]
But yeah, like about
25%, so it's different.
For me, I can't front.
It's very different.
I think that I'd like
to say to both sides,
OK, the side over here, old
Oakland, that was amazing.
That happened.
Everything changes.
We got to get with
this new Oakland
and welcome them in and be
excited to see them and find
out ways that we
can work with them.
And I like to say to the
people in the new Oakland,
I like to ask them,
why's Oakland cool?
Somebody made it cool.
Me-- no, not me, but somebody--
[LAUGHTER]
Someone made it
cool, and there's
a reason why you get
this feeling, man, you're
in the Bay Area.
There's all these vibrations.
And they're like, yeah.
It's hella cool.
You tell this--
There's a reason.
People paid a lot of
dues and sacrificed a lot
to make you feel that way.
So be very respectful of
that and try to include.
And then we all
find a way to try
to make it a really
delicious pot of soup.
That's organic and all that,
but got some pig fat in it.
[LAUGHTER]
The album is a lot about
my feeling of that.
It's interesting because
I was in New Orleans
when I came up with that title.
Because wherever I was
going in the US at the time,
it just felt like there
was this huge shift.
It felt like people
weren't going
to be able to afford to live
in these really cool places.
They're cool, and they
have coffee shops.
And they're fancy.
You know, it's going to be
boring in about 10 years
if you're not careful
about really understanding
why the city was
great, it was cool.
When I went to Europe
just in the last month,
I kind of had the same feeling,
like in Paris and London,
especially.
It's just super,
super expensive.
And all the artists and
cool people are leaving.
JAMES DRISCOLL: So what can
we do to keep Oakland cool?
Because what's
going on in Oakland
is also going on
in San Francisco.
It's going on in New York.
How does a place change
but keep that soul
that makes it so desirable,
that attracts people
from all over the world?
FANTASTIC NEGRITO:
Give us money.
[LAUGHTER]
Let him answer that.
JAMES DRISCOLL: By the way,
I want to introduce you.
So this is Malcolm Spellman.
He's a writer and
producer for "Empire."
And he came up with
Xavier, Fantastic Negrito.
I'm going to let him talk
about that a little bit later.
MALCOLM SPELLMAN: Yeah,
we've been around each other,
had very similar
trajectories in our careers
with the starts and stops,
his a little bit more
dramatic than mine.
But that's why he's
the entertainer.
FANTASTIC NEGRITO: That's
why I'm sitting here.
MALCOLM SPELLMAN:
I think you have
to be real about how
grim the reality is.
Like, what he's
saying is important.
There is a counterculture.
Oakland's a city
of 300,000 people
and has a national imprint
on the level of New York
and Los Angeles, everything.
And the Hells Angels
came out of Oakland.
The Oakland Raiders came out--
you know what I'm saying?
That's done, right?
And now it's the remnants there.
As these new companies
and new entities come in,
there's a value to
what's been driven out.
And there should be a
sense of obligation.
I think this country in
general, what makes it amazing
is we innovate and
we course correct.
And we just do shit.
Whatever it takes to
win, we do that to win.
The problem with that is
we don't really believe,
not in a national way, we don't
value tradition and culture
and ritual, whatever.
And so I think
the first thing is
that we talk about how
you keep Oakland cool,
you've got to recognize most
of what was cool about Oakland
and this tiny city that had
this giant imprint is gone.
And there's this giant
super entity coming in,
stomping something out.
It's like this giant
comes into a town
and wants to save the
villagers down there
and is stomping on their
houses or whatever.
FANTASTIC NEGRITO: [INAUDIBLE].
MALCOLM SPELLMAN: And the
first thing you have to do
is fucking stop and
acknowledge there's
very little of this left.
And then you ask them
what can be done now.
If we encroach, if we come your
way, we're not of your world.
We don't know-- and our
abilities and our movements
are so big and potent.
We don't know how to
preserve what this is.
It has to come, I think,
from the other side.
FANTASTIC NEGRITO: I
think some of the people
are on the other side,
but yeah, he's right.
MALCOLM SPELLMAN:
Yeah, it has-- yeah.
[LAUGHS]
FANTASTIC NEGRITO: I just
said some of the people.
You can't ask all of them.
MALCOLM SPELLMAN: Yeah.
FANTASTIC NEGRITO: We
grew up with all of them.
We know.
JAMES DRISCOLL: So it sounds
like building bridges,
creating a dialogue,
having communication.
And it seems like-- what
strikes me about your music
is art brings people together.
FANTASTIC NEGRITO:
Yeah, that's true.
JAMES DRISCOLL: You don't have
to have any amount of money
or be from anywhere to listen
to your music or any music
and be moved.
And so how do you see
your music or just art
having the potential to
bring people together,
to start these discussions, to
stop the giants from stomping
on the people and just
build something together?
FANTASTIC NEGRITO: Well, I
know that I overuse the word
honesty and authenticity.
But I think that for
myself personally,
when I came up with the
idea of Fantastic Negrito,
I thought, man, this is amazing.
And I thought, why
don't I go and play
this music for the people
in the city that live in,
the people that
don't to hear it?
And so what I would do--
that kept it honest.
I'd go out at 5:00 PM.
You'd go to BART, start playing.
Hey, here's my song.
They're trying to get home.
And I think if I could
connect with those people
that there was-- that
connection was very real.
Because these people, they
didn't come pay to see you.
They want to go home.
Or like 2:00 AM in front
of Colonial Donuts,
after people have been drinking.
They do not care about anything.
But if you can
connect with them,
then there's something
in the music.
And I think will all art and all
very creative people, I always
say this, is this is our time.
If you're creative,
man, get busy
now because people need
you now more than ever.
Because our so-called
leaders, whoever they are,
they're completely
bought and sold.
And they listen to someone else.
And they're not very
genuine, and they
don't have you in mind.
But I think people
can look to artists,
and it's our responsibility to
be the kind of light out there
and be willing to take chances--
something that we learned
from David Bowe, something
that we learned from Prince,
a couple of people that are
big influencers to me-- the
take chances artists.
And people really need you.
JAMES DRISCOLL: So thinking
about taking chances.
The two of you are sitting here.
You just came out
with a new album.
Your profile the
music industry has
skyrocketed in the last year.
You're writing and producing
one of the most popular shows
on TV.
So you're pretty successful,
but you both came from Oakland.
How did that happen?
How did your creativity
and your innovation
get you from there to here?
FANTASTIC NEGRITO: You mean
right here at Google today?
JAMES DRISCOLL:
Right here at Google,
where you are after this,
where you are on Monday
at a Bernie Sanders
rally playing
for thousands of people.
FANTASTIC NEGRITO: Do you
want to talk about it?
MALCOLM SPELLMAN: It will take
up the rest of this interview
if I do it.
[LAUGHTER]
For him, we had a
mutual friend in common.
And we were being knuckleheads
in the industry to whatever.
And he had an encounter that
was very, very dangerous,
when we were caught up in the
streets, hustling, whatever,
right?
And he had been really,
really attracted to music,
leading up to this time.
So we knew each other,
weren't really tight,
but we both had the
same best friend.
And this encounter sent
him to Los Angeles, right?
While he was in LA, I ended
up getting into some trouble
out here also.
And so a few years behind
him, with this best friend,
me and his best friend
had to move to LA.
We had to get out the Bay Area.
During this time-- I'm
forgetting the exact time
frame or whatever-- he
got a huge record deal.
FANTASTIC NEGRITO: Bigger
than anyone else's.
MALCOLM SPELLMAN:
At the time, it
was the biggest record deal
ever For an unsigned artist.
And that turned into a disaster.
And mind you--
[LAUGHTER]
--me and him hate each
other at this time.
We have this mutual best friend.
FANTASTIC NEGRITO: We're
competing for the best friend.
Look at me.
MALCOLM SPELLMAN: While he
has his record deal going,
I break into Hollywood.
I write a spec script,
sell it to Fox or whatever.
And I'm now the hot
dude who came out
of nowhere in Hollywood.
And I'm making it
as a screenwriter.
And I'm a little bit behind him.
His trajectory's ahead of mine.
A few more famously tragic
things happen to this cat,
beyond like the label
sort of not knowing
what to do with him and him
not being-- he was a kid.
He was in his 20s.
Him not having
enough of an identity
to penetrate the giant
label's lack of vision.
And so he got shelved, then
got into a car accident.
He fucked up his hand, mangled
his hand, his whole body.
FANTASTIC NEGRITO:
My hand is mangled.
MALCOLM SPELLMAN: Years
of rehab or whatever.
For me, a similar thing
happened, less dramatic
of course.
But my career went dead,
completely out of Hollywood,
lost all my agents.
Was not on the radar, whatever.
And when he was in
the hospital, that's
when me and him got tight.
It's just too real.
FANTASTIC NEGRITO:
Yeah it was real.
When I heard-- I mean, he
came to see me every day.
I was in a coma three weeks.
And Malcolm came every day.
And I was like, wow.
That was kind of moving.
MALCOLM SPELLMAN: I
hated this motherfucker.
FANTASTIC NEGRITO: He hated--
[LAUGHTER]
I hated him too.
I think we hated each other when
our eyes met in high school.
I was like, I hate him.
He was like, I hate him.
We had a legacy of hate.
And, yeah, so what happens
is I'm in this coma.
I'm mangled.
Man, I have all these braces.
I look crazy.
I used to walk up to
your apartment sometime,
because we were
not too far away.
So then I decided to get into
the illegal nightclub business.
MALCOLM SPELLMAN: Yep.
FANTASTIC NEGRITO:
And so I'd open up
these illegal nightclubs.
And everybody would come.
Celebrities would all come.
But they'd open at midnight and
close at 6:00-- best parties.
Best parties.
And I only got arrested once.
And he was kind of part of it.
MALCOLM SPELLMAN: Motherfucker,
yes, I was part of it.
FANTASTIC NEGRITO:
Yeah, he was part of it.
MALCOLM SPELLMAN: Instrumental.
FANTASTIC NEGRITO:
I'm a terrible--
MALCOLM SPELLMAN: [LAUGHS]
FANTASTIC NEGRITO: I'm terrible.
I'm the worst.
But I was still growing
as a human being.
I was very mean.
But let's get past that part.
And then I took the--
MALCOLM SPELLMAN: Let's
get you back to Oakland.
FANTASTIC NEGRITO: Oh,
back to Oakland already?
MALCOLM SPELLMAN: Yeah.
FANTASTIC NEGRITO:
We're back to Oakland.
MALCOLM SPELLMAN: And has a kid.
FANTASTIC NEGRITO: I had a kid.
MALCOLM SPELLMAN: And I'm
slowly rebuilding my career
in Hollywood, which is
extremely difficult.
And the kid inspires
him to start
playing music or whatever.
And we have now
become like brothers,
you know what I'm saying?
And we were already family, but
now we operated like brothers.
And we had a pot thing
going up in open.
FANTASTIC NEGRITO:
We had a very nice--
MALCOLM SPELLMAN: This
is the kind of guy I am.
He was like, all
right, Malcolm, I'm
ready to go all the way
in with the music thing.
And I gave up my half
of the weed organization
and gave-- I was like,
just let that fund you.
Because of his background,
he struggled a lot as a kid.
And he was out on his own.
He is terribly
uncomfortable with help,
and he is terribly
uncomfortable with the idea--
like when he sits
here and tells you
guys about having
a collective, it
took a lot for him
to get to the point
that he would be able to admit
I have these people who support
me, and I can't move without.
And even when I said, yo, dude,
you can take over this thing,
and you can keep the
money, he was like, naw,
naw, I'll pay you
back, don't worry.
I'm going to give
you this money back.
He wouldn't let it be a
partnership initially.
He starts making this music.
He grows more and
more comfortable.
We started battling
over the music.
Again, as a
creative, I think one
of the things that got him in
trouble with the record deal
is Xavier likes a lot
of music and if you
let him go will just
play a lot of everything.
His first album
sounded like what
his fifth album should've been.
And so my job was to pin
him down and say, yo dude,
you know, we're old now.
FANTASTIC NEGRITO:
We're damn old.
MALCOLM SPELLMAN:
It's time to get real,
and if you've got to
put something out there,
what do you want to do?
FANTASTIC NEGRITO: I
remember that conversation.
He asked me what I wanted to do.
Because we'd grown all the weed.
That was great.
It was great for
a lot of you too.
[LAUGHTER]
We had the best weed
in the Bay Area.
That's what they would say.
It's always the best with us.
It's always the best.
Get used to it.
And I remember.
He was like, man, you know, you
should get back in the music.
And I wanted to
get back into it.
But I was terrified.
And he's like, what
do you really like?
And I said, what
do I really love?
Really at this point I'm
listening to this black root
stuff, this old
black roots music
that, say, my grandfather
and her one armed brother
used to listen to on the porch
in deep Southern Virginia
when I used to visit them,
drinking Johnnie Walker
Red and grape juice.
I said, I'm listening to that.
But I couldn't imagine that
what my take on that would be.
And I couldn't imagine that
anyone would be interested.
But the good thing about
being in a collective
and not having all the
power is that I really
had other people, such
as Malcolm, mainly--
Malcolm all the way, actually--
to help guide me so I wouldn't
go off and write an opera.
Because I'll do that
and be like, oh, look,
I wrote an opera.
And that really helped
Fantastic Negrito stay on track,
and it was good to be
challenged and someone
could tell me that sucks.
I grew up with you.
We robbed people together.
We did this together.
And I know who you are.
You buried your brother,
like shit like that.
I'm like, aw, man,
why'd you say that?
Now I hate you, really.
And it helped the songs remain
very genuine and edgy, as I am
and as the Bay Area is.
I think everyone should
join a collective.
Google, become a collective.
It's better.
MALCOLM SPELLMAN:
It fancies itself
as a collective, a giant,
world-conquering collective.
FANTASTIC NEGRITO:
Yeah, world-conquering.
I really learned as
a creative person
that you erally-- I
remember, I was 40 years,
and it just hit me.
I was like, damn, you
can't do this alone.
You young people,
don't wait till your 40
to figure that out.
Because it's just stagnation.
I mean, I was such
an ego maniac.
I mean, I still am,
but I'm in check now,
you know what I mean?
I just couldn't believe
that you needed people.
I'd grown up on
the streets, man.
I left home at 12,
and I never came back.
My father died, whatever.
I see my mother
again when I was 19.
I was an independent dude.
So yeah, the power of sharing.
It's amazing.
Share that power.
You can't do it alone.
JAMES DRISCOLL: You're
talking about sharing power,
but you're also
sharing your music.
And it makes me wonder
what your intention is.
One of my favorite
lyrics of yours
is, "I'm trying to rehabilitate
from the self-hate."
Is music just a catharsis, a
way for you to heal yourself?
Or is it something more?
FANTASTIC NEGRITO: Some
people call them gigs.
I call it therapy.
For me, it's just therapy.
It's like it's a platform where
I can be completely naked.
And that's why I have such
terrible stage fright,
and it always takes so
much to get up here, man.
Because it's probably the
purest that one can catch
me is up there,
singing those songs.
And I found out,
which I always think
everything's about
me-- what I found out
was that it was helpful
to other people.
And then I latched onto that.
And I said, see, look.
I'm doing something good.
So yeah, so I
think it's probably
therapeutic for everyone.
Because there always has to be
someone who will say it-- it.
I'll say it, even if it
makes people uncomfortable.
It's OK.
JAMES DRISCOLL: I'm
wondering, Malcolm, for you,
you're an artist as well
with what you write.
What's your intention?
Is it also rehabilitation?
Is it making money?
Is it connecting with people
and trying to change the world?
MALCOLM SPELLMAN: Yeah,
I make money to get him.
[LAUGHTER]
No, It's different.
It's twofold because I
feel like on "Empire,"
that is an entertainment show.
And it does investigate shit
that people need to see.
Like, it was a big deal for
a young black gay character
to come out in that world.
But the primary imperative on
that show is entertainment.
It's fun.
And that's what we have
to do first and foremost.
When I'm working with
him, and again, my job
is mostly to--
but it's creative.
It taps into the same thing.
FANTASTIC NEGRITO:
Very creative.
MALCOLM SPELLMAN: When I'm
working with him, it's fun.
It's very, very gratifying
and challenging because he
is a dude, like-- you guys
have probably heard the story.
I've been around
for a long time,
and I know what's real with
this dude and I know what's not.
And I know when he's resisting
the layers that he has.
And so, creatively for me, it is
about wrangling this dude down
and trying to find a
specificity and something that's
all his own-- get
him into something
that's very specifically his.
Because when he can do
that, at that point,
and when you're in the
realm of true honesty
and not being guarded and
letting some shit just
go out there or whatever, the
specificity of your own stuff
is actually universal.
So for me, guiding thing
is specificity and honesty
from him.
And I do consider that a
creative process, even though--
FANTASTIC NEGRITO:
It's very creative.
I think it's the hardest
thing in the world
to do for-- stop
yawning or get out.
I'm just kidding.
[LAUGHTER]
It hurts my massive ego.
Being honest.
But I do love you though.
So does Jesus!
And all the other gods,
they all love you.
So yeah, being honest is
the hardest fucking thing
in the world, at
least it is for me.
But I think that
it is universal.
And we need help getting there
or we self-destruct on pills,
liquor, drugs.
I mean, the entertainment
business actually kills people,
if you think about.
Kurt Cobain, just Prince.
MALCOLM SPELLMAN: Kind of me.
FANTASTIC NEGRITO: Who?
MALCOLM SPELLMAN: Me.
FANTASTIC NEGRITO: Him, he's
dying right now, right in front
of you.
No, it's a killer.
Because-- I don't know--
they commodify your soul,
your spirit, and that's weird.
And being creative is
a very sacred task.
But when it's mixed
with capitalism,
it becomes weird quick.
AUDIENCE: Buy my album.
FANTASTIC NEGRITO:
[CHUCKLES] Buy my album.
Buy my soul!
JAMES DRISCOLL: So
where do you think
the balance is between being
creative, creating connections,
and the reality that we do have
a capitalism system, society
that we live in?
FANTASTIC NEGRITO: I
think you just better
have people to help you.
MALCOLM SPELLMAN: Yeah,
again, that's me and him.
And I think you have to
understand you compromise
as little as possible.
First of all, you understand
the price of compromise.
And it's great.
It is to be successful
on a high level.
Like, every single
ring of success
ultimately is a massive amount
of compromise creatively
and integrity to get there.
So for us, what
we cherish, is we
don't allow anyone to talk
about hits, record sales, data.
We don't allow none
of that shit so
that if anyone
comes to us, what we
hope is going to happen, with
the reaction to his music
is that if we are pure
while he's in that studio,
and that it does not matter
if one single person likes
this song or whatever,
he can stand behind it.
It's real.
It's got its own sound.
It was all done in 100% earnest.
You take that out to the world,
and then the compromises begin.
But in the studio, there are
zero, zero, zero compromises.
He can cuss.
Oh, won't be on the radio.
It's too long.
It won't be on record.
No compromises in there.
Then you take it out to world.
What the world is
recognizing when
they see this dude is
that vibe and that-- I
don't if the word-- culture,
whatever, that's behind it.
And that allows us-- you
do have make compromises.
When he goes on a
stage, he might not
be like-- if you all were
going to give this man 50 grand
and said but you can't cuss,
he's not going to cuss.
Those are the
compromises you make
because that's after the fact.
So you see what I'm saying?
Once you leave
the studio, that's
when the compromises begin.
FANTASTIC NEGRITO: That's true.
I agree, yeah, 100%.
MALCOLM SPELLMAN:
What we don't allow
still is any conversations
about the money
it takes to feed his family.
They cannot come into
the creation stage.
All that has to happen
outside of the creation stage.
FANTASTIC NEGRITO: Yeah, because
you can't underestimate people.
I mean, by just
feeding them over
and over again this formulaic
cookie cutter music that you
hear, or movies that
you see, that people
are a lot smarter than
marketers think, I believe.
They want to hear
all kinds of things.
JAMES DRISCOLL: So one theme
that I heard from both of you,
especially in talking
about your stories,
was rebirth-- from
the car accident,
from the lives that
you guys were leading.
How do you see rebirth
playing into your music?
Do you have the intention
for the audience that
here's your music to
feel some kind of rebirth
within themselves?
Do you feel like
Oakland needs a rebirth
or it's in the
middle of a rebirth?
Or did Oakland not even
die in the first place?
What do you think about rebirth?
FANTASTIC NEGRITO: That's
a lot to think about.
You gonna have a rebirth?
OK.
Get ready.
No, I don't think about that.
I think about contributing.
That's always my big word.
I mean, as a human being,
all of us have this value.
And we all have an experience.
And what makes a great
family, which is what we are,
whether we want
to be one or not--
we're kind of this
human family--
is that we all contribute.
And so I think what I get out
of it-- you can cut me off
in a minute-- is just a
contribution to people.
MALCOLM SPELLMAN: But I think
particularly because his story
is a literal like--
the story of rebirth,
that's what I'm most proud of.
Way more than working
on successful shit,
I'm proud that I
survived and got
to a point where a lot of people
dropped off and got there.
But I don't only care about
that because it's screenwriting.
For him, this story
of rebirth, I think,
is probably the primary thing
because people of every age
or whatever are failing
and giving up on dreams.
And I've seen-- this
dude has a heart.
When he tells a story, he likes
to be the hero of his stories,
and sometimes he talks
about, oh, you know.
I left Interscope
and [INAUDIBLE],
and I never gave up.
But that's actually not true.
He literally gave up.
First of all, he almost died.
He got--
FANTASTIC NEGRITO: That
was almost, though.
MALCOLM SPELLMAN: That's true.
He did not give up
when they were talking
about cutting his arm off.
But he sold all his music.
I'm telling you, I've seen it.
He sold all his
musical equipment.
He used to call me up and make
fun of people who made music.
FANTASTIC NEGRITO: [LAUGHS]
MALCOLM SPELLMAN: He'd be like--
FANTASTIC NEGRITO: That's true.
MALCOLM SPELLMAN: --fucking
idiots, making music.
So that's how far he went.
And I think that that's what
makes his message so potent
is because at the forefront
of it is true, true rebirth.
And the fact that if a dude can
completely give up, and then
come back from that
in his 40s, whatever
it is that we're harboring--
because we're all harboring
a lot of damage and stunted
dreams or whatever-- yes,
that's what it's tapping into.
That narrative of his
is tapping into the fact
that everybody in this
room, something died.
It could be a romantic.
It could be a dream
to have a business.
Whatever it is.
And there's always hope.
FANTASTIC NEGRITO:
That's why I have him.
He thinks about all this stuff.
He's much smarter than me.
JAMES DRISCOLL:
Well, Malcolm, I'm
also interested in
your perspective
on-- you write for a show
that's about making music
in the music industry.
And then you're also
making music with Xavier.
And how much does
reality reflect what--
MALCOLM SPELLMAN:
It helps a lot.
It really does.
You don't even know
that, but it is
watching what he goes through.
When you're dealing
with Hollywood stuff
on a big level with
a giant production,
a dash of authenticity
goes a million miles.
It really does.
Because so much of
the shit that's out
there is completely fraudulent.
And it's still fun,
but you don't feel
like there was nothing there.
It's missing those
details that make you say,
man, somebody really,
really touched on something
real at least in this moment.
And dealing with him,
I'm able to a lot
of times infuse that
into the stories that
come out of that writers' room.
JAMES DRISCOLL: Do
you watch "Empire"?
FANTASTIC NEGRITO:
I do when I can.
I do.
AUDIENCE: When you're on it.
FANTASTIC NEGRITO:
Yeah, when I'm on it.
Naw, that's a lie.
It's a lie.
It's just terrible!
MALCOLM SPELLMAN: Ep 2, 15.
FANTASTIC NEGRITO: No,
no, I do when I can.
I'm touring a lot.
I binged on the first season,
some of the second season.
I haven't even seen my episode.
It's been so busy.
I did like 45 days, 43 dates
in four different continents.
I came back.
Then I'm in San Diego.
I'm in Los Angeles.
It's kind of been nonstop.
When I get my chance, I
watch everything that I can.
JAMES DRISCOLL:
And with touring,
how does that affect
you as a songwriter?
Are you writing anything?
Or do you feel like you're so
depleted after working so hard?
FANTASTIC NEGRITO: You
know, my saving grace
was always that I
could write songs
over and over and over again.
So the songs are always there.
They're not always good,
but they're always there.
So I think touring can help.
You're in a different country
sometimes every other day.
And there's a lot to
take from that experience
and traveling, watching
people, interacting
with different people.
And just playing
the songs, I mean,
I just came off a tour where I
was playing in symphony halls.
And that was bizarre.
You know, you're sitting
there with the guitar
at the Royal Albert Hall and
all these different places.
So that has a really
different dynamic.
JAMES DRISCOLL: And has your
opinion or feeling about people
just in general change
from touring and playing
in front of so many
people, sharing your music
with so many different audiences
in so many different places?
FANTASTIC NEGRITO: Well, I've
definitely learned a lot.
And I give Chris
Cornell a lot of credit
because I just sat
and watched him
because I was opening for him.
I was like, this is
so weird, sitting up
in front of these people.
It's kind of like this.
They sit down.
And people don't usually
sit down at my shows.
So it was an education.
You get to test out how
good your songs are.
Because these are like
Scandinavians, Germans,
Viennese-- what are
they, from Vienna?
Those people.
Croatians, all kinds
of different people.
So you're definitely
learning how
to deliver it, how to put
your own story into it.
MALCOLM SPELLMAN: What
about the people have you
noticed like from when you
broke in and had nobody.
You were playing Van Cleef
or whatever, then Tiny Desk,
and touring to now.
What do you see coming
at you as far as who's
listening to your music?
Or has that surprised
you, who likes
your music, who jives with it?
FANTASTIC NEGRITO: I always feel
like my audience is thirsty.
I think Field came up with that.
That's Field.
He's another guy in
the collective, the guy
with the shiny dome back there.
[LAUGHS]
We all love each other.
Yeah, I think they're thirsty.
I look at my audience,
no matter what country
it is, they want something.
And I think they
may have opinions,
and they want someone to say it.
Of course, from "Empire,"
now we get all the brothers,
get like all the tough guys.
I'm like, damn, they come too.
That's interesting.
They'll be like, man, I
don't even buy music, man,
but I'm buying your shit.
And that's cool.
So sometimes my
shows can be odd.
You see grandma and teenagers.
MALCOLM SPELLMAN: That's a trip.
That is a trip.
FANTASTIC NEGRITO:
It's these kids
like-- the kids will
be like, I've never
seen anything like this before.
And then the old
people are like,
I remember when they
played songs like that.
MALCOLM SPELLMAN:
You get uncomfortable
when little kids are
there too, right?
FANTASTIC NEGRITO:
Say that again.
MALCOLM SPELLMAN:
You get uncomfortable
when little kids are
there sometimes, right?
FANTASTIC NEGRITO: Yeah,
because sometimes I
wonder if-- I don't know
if they're ready to hear
some of the content.
But sure they are.
There's people who
bring their kids.
And I'm like, wow, you're
bringing your kids.
Because I wouldn't bring mine.
[LAUGHTER]
Because this guy is fucked up.
But it's good.
Maybe that's good.
Maybe we need to
see fucked up as
long as it's not evil
or trying to get you
or anything like that.
It's part of the spectrum.
So when you have kids,
all that changes.
You get nervous.
But no, I have a very
interesting audience,
I'll say that.
[WHISTLES] All over.
JAMES DRISCOLL:
Well, given that,
thank you so much
for coming today
and for sharing
your music with us.
Keep making a lot
more of it, please.
FANTASTIC NEGRITO: Thank
you so much for having us.
JAMES DRISCOLL: Cool, thanks.
FANTASTIC NEGRITO: All right.
[APPLAUSE]